Hi Everyone,
back on February 20th,
I announced that I was going to go to 12
different cities in North America and
talk about my new book,
12 rules for life and a variety of other
things and so we arranged theaters and
put those tickets up for sale and
they've proved very popular.
I did the first one this week on Sunday
in New York at the beacon theater to an
audience of about 3000 people and it
seemed to go very well.
The consequences of that is that I'm now
announcing another 20 cities and this is
the video to make that announcement.
I'm also appearing as a guest with
several other speakers,
including Matt Dillahunty,
Sam Harris,
a number of times,
and also Sam Harris and Douglas Murray,
and so the announcements for those who
will be included in the description of
this video as well.
All these talks are going to occur from
may through June,
and I'll just list the cities.
You can get the cities and the dates
below.
Toronto,
Washington,
Chicago,
Detroit,
Denver,
San Francisco,
Seattle,
London,
Toronto,
Boston,
Philadelphia,
and Houston,
Dallas,
Austin,
and Phoenix.
Brick,
Jeevak,
Washington and Richmond.
Charlotte,
Nashville and Atlanta,
Louisville,
Indianapolis and Milwaukee,
Minneapolis,
Seattle,
and Vancouver.
That's twice with Sam Harris,
Portland,
Sacramento and San Diego,
Long Beach Thousand Oaks,
and finally Dublin with Sam Harris and
Douglas Murray.
I've done about 10 of these talks
already.
Three in London.
One announced her damn one in La,
San Francisco,
Vancouver,
Toronto,
and New York.
I really looked forward to them and it's
a real privilege to be able to speak
about important issues pertaining to
psychological development within
enthusiastic and involved crowd and I
hope that the lectures are useful and,
and that there is useful for the people
that I'm speaking with as they are
engaging and worthwhile for me.
So if you'd like to buy a ticket then
I'd like to see you there and I look
forward to seeing you in your hometown
in May and June.
So thanks very much for your continued
support.
I hope we get a chance to have a
meaningful and productive evening in the
very near future.
Bye Bye.